it's like it's like 21 questions
probably when they narrow it down really
quick exactly the first question is a
boy or a girl are they dead or alive
like is this Asian are all the big noses
we're taking them out
[Music]
uh does anybody watch the Netflix True
Crime show Unsolved Mysteries yeah I've
seen a couple episodes have you yeah
what do you say do they Solve IT disdain
because sometimes I actually
when I was watching it I realized I
realized it wasn't as a spicy as I
thought it was oh
so you wanted more depth more gold not
even [__] up stuff you actually after
a while
I'm thinking this out loud as I'm
talking about this I'm processing it out
loud I think when you watch it you
realize like man all these are just
really sad like they're just so like and
they're sad because they're all unsolved
too yeah so it's really like damn well
they didn't catch the guy they didn't
you know you don't get closure off any
episode yeah you see everyone cry you
see the whole family cry about it and
people talk about something yeah I know
I know
who didn't who [__] did it why are
you was like
yeah because that's like hey man don't
make fun of me oh dead babies maybe I'll
smile from this
maybe there's one that's not bad yeah
yeah maybe because this whole time I'm
thinking you just like watching shows
with no closure yeah that's what I
thought but that's why I stopped
watching it like I watched a couple of
episodes and I was like I'm over this so
they tricked you yeah no it's good the
trailers are good it'll be closure no no
no no it's not that it's not that so why
are they so mysterious
how are they gonna solve this it's like
yeah you just don't realize like you
think it's gonna be entertaining and
then I think that's what it is you think
it's gonna be entertaining and it kind
of is but then it's just really sad what
if there's a show called solved
Mysteries I'm like let's do this baby
let's get into it well on one of the
episodes of Unsolved Mysteries there was
a episode called abducted by a parent
it was about a story about a girl named
Kayla
um
nice yeah just German in the show it
sounds like it in the show viewers heard
that Kayla disappeared from her home
state of Illinois in 2017 along with her
mother who had been visiting for July
4th the day after the visit Kayla's dad
who had full customer custody of her
went to pick her up but found both
mother and daughter Missy oh got the
police involved in a massive search
operation was launched Kayla wasn't ever
able to be located
she's featured on this show though yeah
and somebody happens to watch his show
so this girl has could have been you
that's been found six years after she
was kidnapped because somebody
recognized her from the Netflix TV wow
wow so that's that's how you're supposed
to watch it you're supposed to stop
watching and then go find the guy not
just go that wasn't entertaining
seriously Nick what have you done
you're the only one that watches the
show and you can't even help you guys
are guilt-tripping me now that's [__]
up man you guys turn the gun back on me
we're just examining the evidence what
have you done to solve these unsolvable
Mysteries yeah you know what it is as a
as a [__] American viewer you're
like what the [__] dude why am I mad
that I picked this show yeah you watch
something else that's what I do I'm
gonna watch Seinfeld instead I'm gonna
watch the episode I've seen 50 times
around don't you know that the
indifference of Good Men is just as evil
as evil men I don't know what your
fortune cookie was that was that from
Austin power yeah yeah definitely it's
way too much English I don't even know
what indifference means so joke's on you
Anthony
yeah dude that's pretty tight that
somebody found like the girl though
that's awesome so in the last moment
what a bad person that girl is mind your
business okay it's not your crime it's
not your mystery well they need to
cancel that episode because it's solved
now take it off that one uh false
advertisement I remember there was I
think I think this was on Unsolved
Mysteries I think it was one where
um this family disappeared and they
couldn't find it was there in France
France or something they couldn't figure
out where they were and they're like I
don't know everyone was like they just
vanished off the face of the Earth and
then they were all dead under the the
like patio oh so that's assault the
mystery yeah but that was I think one of
the episodes so I was like uh so it's
solved yeah yeah so they don't know how
they don't know the method huh yeah yeah
I think one person was missing parts of
it is unsolved yeah parts of it unsolved
but then it's like okay well
you know well it wasn't me yeah yeah
yeah there was a body yeah it's not
called unfindable bodies now that's a
good show that's a really good job
where's the
box
no matter what it's called he hates it
they're so pleasing this guy that's what
it really is so in the last month the
U.S national Center for missing an
exploited Children released this aged up
photo uh showing what Kayla might look
like which eventually led to a sighting
more than 600 miles away in wow it was
actually accurate enough yeah the owner
of a shop in Asheville recognized Kayla
in a shopping center from the series and
reported deciding they called police who
took her in a protective custody her
mother was arrested and charged with one
count of child abduction according to
the King County state attorney's office
and her bill set at a quarter million
dude that's crazy because it's not like
it's a person that knows her and was
like Hey That's you that's a cold
sighting right you know how many of
those come in like all the time and
they're just wrong and Netflix is like
we get views baby and this is off of
like an aged up photo yeah dude and
their eyes are so good yeah that's
[__] question that's even more
remarkable to like where did confident
enough to look at that person be like
this has to be yeah that's you because I
miss spot people all the time see mind
your business like all these people's
dot uh doppelgangers
so someone that's a fake photo that's
aged up I think this is the age it up
one and then they're like the other
picture of her like in real life to see
how close it is no dude if I watch that
show and that girl walked into my shop I
would have been like yeah whatever I
wouldn't even it's not gonna make an
impression on me no dude yeah plus
that's like assuming that you're even
still thinking about that show maybe
maybe that person watched that episode
like that night you know what I mean the
day right before or something like that
so like everything was just fresh in the
mind yeah dude water though or they just
did a better job than Nick you know
yeah they felt their civic duty kick in
they're just a better person or or that
person calls like once a month saying I
found this oh my God and it just hits
finally finally got it right yeah
crazy collar
I can't even remember the same fan I've
met three times you know like I met you
at UC Irvine I'm like
is it because all Asians look the same
is that why I think so you said it rude
disguise I'm sorry I'm sorry like do you
like if you order food somewhere do you
remember what the worker looks like I've
known hell no sometimes no you do
they're unique looking no so if they're
hot they're weird looking well the
hardest thing would be you know when you
have to describe to a police sketch
artist what someone looks like that's
super hard and they know the word how do
they know the words like what's the
what's this part called I don't know the
upper lip is it see I don't even know
how to describe anything but all I know
is like round face fat rectangular face
that's all I know oval yeah because uh I
know that the sketch artist asks you
questions it's normally you're not just
sitting there like describing they they
know how to like narrow it down so
they'll like be like is it this kind of
nose is it that nose and they ask you if
it's getting closer to how they looked
or farther away that makes more sense
because at least they have enough
experience they're the experts yeah yeah
that because I can't describe anything
it's like it's like 21 questions
probably when they narrow it down really
quick exactly the first question is a
boy or a girl are they dead or alive is
this Asian are all the big noses we're
taking them out right right it's like
guess who yeah are they a boy or girl
they're they Guess Who in real easy
half a shaved head they got tattoos here
you know what I mean what kind of eyes
slanted yeah a little more slantier yeah
that's a hard thing dude oh Japanese
then okay that's why them shits always
come out looking nothing like the guy
yeah so that was the hit don't they
there's that you guys know Mark Brown on
ABC that the black oh yeah yeah they're
like yo this is what the suspect looks
like it looks just like
exactly like them that's the best stuff
um you look like Mark Brown
KTLA you see there was one where they
were looking for this murder and the
sketch looked like a child drew it
looked all [__] up but then they found
the guy and he did look like
really looked exactly like that
that's great you've seen those uh
caricature drawings in like Hawaii and
stuff where they like super like diss
you it's like they roast you with it
right yeah those ones are like so
accurate so accurate better than get
your essence you know yeah yeah imagine
if that was a police sketch dude just
characters because they do accentuate
the first thing you see so that kind of
makes sense right yeah how do you guys
feel about internet sleuths I think
they're all wrong I think they can ruin
the collateral damage is massive though
it's like even if they catch the guy
they ruin the lives of Hell other people
all the Netflix documentaries I've
watched where they feature internet
sleuth like the first half of it is how
like they all just destroy the
investigation yeah
oh is that why you don't do anything
yeah okay that's why you know what good
job man because I saw the one the the
Teresa Tam one where the girl at the
Cecil Hotel yeah that one's rough yeah
first off and I've said this on here
before that web series or whatever
Netflix show should have been like one
episode it should have been one episode
yeah it should have been 35 minutes you
in you out and they did the side story
about how they ruined this poor dude
from like water The Rocker dude yeah
yeah that's so sucky and they were like
oh he's goth so he's the one so he must
have did it yeah they [__] he used
his lyrics like murder and I was like
don't all like you know screamo dudes I
don't know I'm not really in the music
but it's like they just destroyed this
dude and this guy it's like they
interview him and he's like crying the
whole time it was sucky man but that's
that was also in that particular
instance the moment that the police
actually decided to open up the case of
the public like posting like videos and
stuff right well it was a great lesson
in like the refusal to believe that the
true story is not remarkable that's true
it was a great lesson of that it's like
hey I know you don't want to think that
this person just had mental issues
because that's not the sexy outcome but
sometimes it's not that great of a story
no it's not
[Music]